da hat dann ein schnee pinkeln der eine
gesenkt der andere cousin nimmt den
schnee wieder drauf gepinkelt hat sich
daran und ist das hallo meine lieben
freunde und herzlich willkommen zur
christmas kraftvoll genug 11.11.11 ja
ich hab ja schon ein neues gen wäre das
schon seht ich habe einfach mal bike
index santa cruz angegeben kann mir
dieses kleine figürchen finde ich ganz
billig den skin vor allem welt sich so
kitschig ist okay das ist schon ein
bisschen kitschig es kitschig vor allem
also das ist schon ein bisschen kitschig
aber jetzt nicht so krass von wegen so
richtig kassel farben sondern schon so
ein bisschen so dunkel rot gestaltet und
so weiter hinten haben die fette berge
wie es schon sehen
jetzt sieht es ganz gut m und zwar leute
hier mit microsoft angehört im
hintergrund wenn alles gut geklappt hat
christliche musik also weihnachtsmusik
gegen rebells umzusetzen quatsch und
viele kennen christmas kraft gar nicht
und zwar was schon mal gemacht und zwar
weil ich somit der erste der so was
gemacht hat so insgesamt die idee so
hatte an weihnachten in minecraft
spezifische videos zu machen sich also
jetzt also ich sag mal videos zu machen
nach dem motto ja jetzt jeden tag ein
video und dann immer etwas bestimmtes
quatsch uns also minecraft haben das
bisher wirklich weniger gemacht deswegen
macht ihr so was machst du so was hab
ich letztes jahr halt gemacht also 2011
im winter ich mach das mal ganz kurzer
dann habt ihr hier die wenigsten was zu
gucken
das habe ich dann gemacht das kam sehr
gut an das habe ich zusammen mit austria
lp gemacht und dieses jahr mache ich das
alleine und zwar wirklich allein beim
park themen quatschen und dabei im
creative bot ein paar gebäude bauen und
letztes jahr musste ich halt die ganzen
tricks rapides löschen weil ich dafür
einen schreck bekommen habe weil ich
keine rechte an den die bahn hatte das
war mir damals gar nicht so bewusst mit
den ganzen liedern doch heutzutage also
ich hab hier zahlt die ganze rechte an
die ganzen lieder nru hallo ich habe
jetzt die ganzen recht an den liedern
die ich nun verwendet
das heißt es geht alles ganz legal über
die bühne sage ich mal
also und zwar was tourismus kraft
eigentlich christmas kräften nutzen wir
die erste folge ist ein bisschen was
einzuläuten wird dann wahrscheinlich
auch ein bisschen kürzer sein weil ich
heute noch nicht wirklich was bauen
werde
christmas kraft ist ganz einfach dass
ich jetzt jeden tag bis zum 24 dezember
bauen werde
in dieser welt hier dass es hier so eine
schneewelt habe ich mich einfach mal den
staat gesucht wir können auch einfach
hierhin fliegen hier sieht einen da
sieht eigentlich ganz schön aus weil es
nicht so schön hier haben wir ein
bisschen mehr platz ist aber eigentlich
auch ganz egal
und zwar werde ich einfach da sind wird
es auch mit ich werde schnee sachen
bauen also sowas wie sei es in
schneeweißen schnee dörfchen sei es
schlitten und soweit sie können jetzt
auch in die kommentare schreiben
und ich werde dann halt jeden tag dazu
ein video machen sage ich mal zu
christmas kraft wie ich das dann bauen
dazu dann über witzige geschichten
quatsch die mir so passiert sind über
dinge die üblich sind an weihnachten was
ich so am tag erlebt habe also quasi ich
sag mal wie loks in form davon dass sich
im hintergrund dann halt auch noch was
bei hier sieht's übrigens schön aus hier
ist wirklich schön
und da ist dann wieder die sache
veränderungen zum letzten jahr ganz
einfach ich habe die möglichkeit durch
mo yan minecraft und break kräfte auch
in der beschreibung stehen weil sie mir
das ermöglichen bzw
die idee dazu gegeben haben und
sponsoren die haben ziemlich viele in
die spieler bei steam und würden die
welt verschenken
und die haben
wie viele spiele haben sie ich glaube
die haben
zwölf spiele das heißt ich würde jetzt
merkt euch die daten am zehnten am 17
und am 24 dezember einfach 24 bin ich
zwei wochen zurück gegangen also 10 17
24 10 17 24 sind die tage da gibt es
jeweils vier spiele spiele also an den
drei tagen gibt's immer vier spielen
bestimmte was soll ich da machen wie
kann ich ein spiel gewinnen und zwar
heute der erste wenn ich dieses video
seht das heißt bis zum 10
ist der erste zweite dritte vierte fünf
der sechs sind dachte dass der neuen
folgen bis zum 10
der zehnte ist ein moment was der
zentrag stattdessen sonntag oder
mercedes a und montag
okay das heißt bis zum 10 sind jetzt
noch genau neun folgen und in diesen
neuen folgen könnt ihr mir immer in die
kommentare schreiben
witzige geschichten die euch an
weihnachten passiert sind witzige
stories witzige fakten über weihnachten
etwas wo ich lachen kann was aber auch
was mit weihnachten zu tun hat also mit
mit schnee usw
zusätzlich dass er schreibt ja da hat
meine oma und blau und hat mir dann das
geschenk mit da musste ich vor lachen
also schon witzige sachen sag ich mal wo
jeder darüber lachen kann und die
witzigsten sachen die drei witzigsten
sachen werde ich raussuchen und werde
die dann sage ich mal am 10
dementsprechend dann jetzt demnächst
also in diesen neuen folgen in den
nächsten neun folgen könnt ihr mit einem
witzige sachen die kommentare schreiben
am zehnten werde ich dann die drei
vierzigsten sachen vorlesen mit auch den
leuten die welt dann auch in die
beschreibung schreiben und diese
personen werden dann von mojang
minecraft angeschrieben bei ihrem
youtube account und bekommen dann
dadurch dann die weiteren informationen
wie ihr das spiel anhalt bekommt das
heißt sie macht das in verbindung mit
mojang minecraft kräfte braucht jetzt
auch nicht schreiben von wegen dialog
addio ist ja gar nicht die machen dass
wir alles alleine blabla nee das ist
nicht so die haben nämlich die idee
gegeben das heißt doch nicht in wie
nachgebessert oder so ich habe auch
nicht dazu bereit erklärt die dann
anzunehmen bei skype die dann den leuten
zu geben also mit einfachen besten wäre
es einfach wenn du den satz sie sollen
ihn anschreiben die sollen mich an
schreiben dann
das also dass ihr wenn ihr gewinnen
wollt ganz einfach in den nächsten
folgen immer witzige geschichten die
kommentare schreiben
den rest das bemerkte ich schon selber
ob ihr gewonnen habt oder nicht ich will
dich mal ganz kurz
also das ist einfach so eine gelegenheit
euch dass er ja auch an den bestimmten
montagen immer geschenke gewinnen könnt
zuerst montag ist quasi die geschenke
tag wir wollten das eigentlich an den
wänden an den agent machen nur das
problem ist dass ich dann heute ist halt
der erste also heute ist ein samstag
oder am sonntag lief es gar nicht wenn
diese folge seite der erste ist ein
samstag genau das heißt das wäre dann
morgen schon wieder der erste event und
dann das wäre ein bisschen schnell wenn
ihr nur eine folge dafür hätte das heißt
wir machen die daten einfach 10 17 24
sep der ihr das heißt ihr könnt immer
kommentare schreiben
mit witzigen geschichten und eventuell
gewinnt die dann irgendwann und dann
erwähne ich eure geschichte euren
youtube kanal und ihr könnt dann auch
noch spiele gewinner ist eigentlich ne
ganz coole sache außerdem könnt ihr dann
halten hier in die kommentare schreiben
über die quatsch und dann will ich sagen
fange ich auch direkt mal an ich habe
jetzt gar kein thema vorbereitet hier
für die erste folge was ich bauen könnte
deswegen versuche ich jetzt einfach mal
einen baum zu baum hier ich das
überhaupt hinkriege was könnte ich den
satz du zb quatschen dem zweck sich
schon an weil ihr solltet ihr die themen
stellen
was haben wir übrigens das schaf design
texture pack das findet passt ganz gut
weil wir hier schnee ist dann ist das
auch wirklich alles weiß und das wollte
ich halt auch so als das was kann ich
denn machen
jetzt müssen baumbusch klopp das ist
dass das ist doch nicht gehabt hätte das
heißt hier so ich bin übrigens nicht so
der beste bauer das tier braucht er
jetzt bin kein bauer
hier braucht setze ich sagen fazit von
scheint aus das weiß ich schon selber
naja ok gut dass das jetzt mal so ein
bisschen schöner aber was kann ich denn
so quatschen schnee also zurzeit ist es
bei uns so bei uns es war noch gar kein
schnee dieses hier also dieses in diesem
winter sage ich mal diese sehr natürlich
schon gehen kann
irgendwann am anfang des jahres aber
jetzt war noch kein schnee und zwar
waren in ganz vielen bundesländern haben
sie alle bei twitter gepostet ja schnee
hier folgen und im fenster waren ganz
normale temperaturen sollen wieso haben
die nie schnee einfach nur bei uns so
typische nordrhein westfalen wo nicht
wie das einige wissen es halt irgendwie
bisschen kaffee die amis glück mit dem
schnee und wenn es ein anderer schneidet
dann immer irgendwie wenn man gerade
irgendwo hinfahren von oder so das ist
einfach typisch
ich meine ich gehe jetzt zur zeit noch
zur schule also ich habe noch keine
ferien
wer auch immer logisch so am ersten dass
man schon ferien hat aber ich wünsche
dir zeit doch eigentlich gar kein schnee
sondern ich will eigentlich viel mehr
dass der schnee kommen wenn ich quasi
ferien hat also sage ich mal an
weihnachten schnee das wäre schon ganz
schön
so schnell findet auch eigentlich ganz
schön anzuschauen ec sagt gar nicht wie
bei euch das hier eigentlich dass man
einfach so jetzt darauf durst das heißt
ich will ich gar nicht so sehr schnell
jetzt im moment sondern ich warte da
eigentlich hätte das eigentlich viel
lieber so wenig in die nicht irgendwo
hin muss sage ich mal
aber das ist einfach immer so dass
schnee immer dann kommt wenn man gerade
irgendwo dadurch fand musste ich diese
ganze matsche pampe das ist einfach so
und ja also bei uns war halt noch gar
kein schwedisches ja was ich denke ich
ein bisschen traurig sogar finde da
hätte ich mich sogar dann aber dazu
bereit erklärt er dann auch durch zu
fahren sagt ich weiß also dass erst mal
so zu schmieren sich eigentlich ziemlich
geil und es gibt ja es gibt ja schnell
ist er weiß und deswegen sieht auch
alles schöner aus und damals war es bei
uns so das ist wirklich immer an
weihnachten die hatten immer das glück
dass es immer geschneidert an
weihnachten als ich klein war
sie legten damals noch in einer anderen
stadt und genau in dem moment fängt es
an zu schneien
das ist doch nicht war oder das ist der
geist der weihnacht dornberger aber echt
krass das jetzt hier und so das ist hier
direkt anfängt zu schneien wenn ich das
sage das ist schon cool hat mich das
symmetrische so viel es ist auch viel
auch 44 gleich nochmal fünf ich weiß
nicht wie hoch dennoch wird jetzt werde
ich immer das glück und die letzten
jahre was ich sag mal seit dem ich so
dass du alles weit so von wegen so alles
machen ja die eltern den man vergibt
seitdem schnaitsee nicht weiß nicht ob
es daran liegt den wie ich bin ich
abergläubisch
und darum geht's nicht legen aber es ist
eben doch ein bisschen verwunderlich mit
demenz ist da und ich da so ein bisschen
skeptisch gegenüber meinen eltern sind
naja ihr wisst was ich meine
es sind ungefährt ob ich vielleicht ein
bisschen als uns ansonsten finde ich mir
auf jeden fall schöner als als dings als
regen
das ist aber glaube ich jeden klar na ja
das gibt's nur für witzige geschichten
mit schnee ja ich weiß noch damals also
ich habe ganz viele cousins die sind
alle ganz ganz klein
die sind so 543 so um den dreh und also
das war halt damals so einfach da und
ich werde halt keine ahnung wie weit
weiter 12 so jedenfalls schneit und da
hat dann einschläge pinkelt der ein
cousin der andere cousin nimmt den
schnee darauf gepinkelt hat sich daran
und ist das also ich bin das ich hab mir
nach hinten sagt du ich wird das nicht
essen mehr so hell warum nicht schwätzen
ist nicht gut und ich wollte nicht sagen
ja den kumpel daran gibt pinkl dir dein
bruder war dann natürlich gesagt erst
mal direkt eine gema belasten zum
witzigen geschichten sag ich mal zum
thema schnee darüber es gibt noch mal
kurz times at 01 er nachher immer noch
hell machen
es gibt sonst so was kann ich sonst noch
so über dinge kämen agil wie schon
gesagt ganz am ziel wieder themen in die
kommentare schreiben
ihr seid er bestimmt ganz ganz kreativ
vor allem wenn das so ganz viele leute
schreiben dann sind da noch viel viel
kreativer als ich als einzelne person
die sich jetzt die 1000 dem ausdenken
muss mit anni und ihr die hat zudem
jetzt schon vorwegnehmen sehe nämlich
jetzt etwa diesem thema wie schnee
übrigens was ja auch mal witzig finde
denn es bei uns damals schneit dann
bleibt der schnee auch liegen einfach
weil es zwar oben kalt genug dass der
schnee runter kommt aber er kann es
nicht liegen bleiben weil kunden der
boden einfach viel zu warm ist oder was
allgemein hier zusammen sind jetzt
physikalische begebenheit ich mir sehr
schlecht in physik physikalische
grundwissen sage ich mal
denn zu verarbeiten kann der schnee und
die liegen bleiben so ganz einfach
übrigens der christmas kraftvoll gewährt
nicht lang gehen sollen so zehn bis
zwölf minuten will ich sagen weil ich
halt im creative modeln und ja da dauert
das hat eigentlich nie so lange so
sachen zu bauen als bei uns bleibt
echten leben fehlen halt auch damals mit
schneeballschlachten gemacht für
mittlerweile ist halt so dass man es
nicht mehr darf sonst würden wir immer
noch machen was ich will sind die
oberstufe mich auf diesen vorschlag
machen weil seine kindischen stufe sind
bin ich ja eigentlich auch ganz mit
zufrieden
man sieht das ist ein baumes ob das
jetzt weihnachtsbaumes darüber lässt
sich dann wiederum streiten warte ich
nicht nehme einfach diese rolle als wenn
das jetzt so kugeln wären bzw
ich packte einfach mal hier noch aus und
packt da mach ich dann blau also ich
mache jeder mal unterschiedlich kommt
jeder jede rote noch mal hin
da und hier oben auch noch mal da haben
wir noch blau das ist ein schönes los
angeles lakers sind schon aus grün pink
finde ich auch ganz süß ist ja voll
schwul
jetzt kann ich zum beispiel wieder einen
normalen jetzt das thema schwule
angeschnitten von wegen ja nur weil
einer pink mag ist also fort spiel aber
nein wir sind bei christoph dass wir
reden über das thema häufig weg nein
keine ahnung
deswegen sollte mit der in die
kommentare schreiben was ihr so viele
themen von mir gesprochen haben falls
club also brauchen aber noch braun
da war schon brauchen das heißt hier
kommt braun blau mission rot ist das
auch schon geld sagt braun
hier kommt pink und hier kommt grün und
da wo ich jetzt fackeln drauf stellen
auf jedes von diesen kleinen dingen
zick-zack also kann auch mal sein dass
ein christmas kraftvoll genug fünf
minuten geht kommt darauf an was ihr mir
sowie sachen den kommentare schreibt
beziehungsweise was sich aufbauen kann
also bau vorschläge betrafen die
kommentare bauen
die konzerne bauen weil ich denke da
gibt es wenige sachen die man bauen kann
so in minecraft von von weihnachts sagt
es gibt allgemein wenig dinge na ja also
das ist erst mal der weihnachtsbaum
würde ich sagen ich mache mal ganz kurz
hier vogel down folge welcher von so ein
foto machen kann
da dies der baum batista twingo dass der
tat ist der baum vor dem jetzt noch
nicht gemacht
das werde ich wollte nur eben vordermann
stimmt ich sagte ja ich weiß foto macht
ein foto und ihm das geld dann
hintergrund packen was schönes nächste
auch nicht schön aus da so eine
schneelandschaft soll so das ist der
baum sieht nicht schön aus ich weil es
alle werden sagen ja du kannst aber auch
nicht bauen und ich weiß ich kann ich
brauch ist einfach so naja jedenfalls
würde ich sagen dass mit der ersten
folge christus kraft wie immer das ist
wie immer erst folge
ihr könnt jetzt in die kommentare
schreiben einerseits und witzige
geschichten von euch mit denen ihr euch
dann quasi direkt dafür bewerben so ein
spiel zu gewinnen als ihr müsst dafür
nicht 18 sein oder so dass es gibt
überhaupt keine voraussetzungen einfach
irgendwelchen witzige story von euch und
kommentare schreiben
dann könnt ihr eventuell ein spiel
gewinnen und zweite sache
themenvorschläge über die quatschen kann
und sachen die ich bauen kann dann will
ich sagen das war es jetzt erst mal von
mir ich würde mich meine bewertung
freund schaffen wir 1000 likes für die
erste christmas kraft folge ist außerdem
der welches opec seite wenn wir das
schaffen wir das recht zu paragraph darf
ich sagen sehen uns beim nächsten mal
und haut rein eine lieben freunde